what earth do you live on a round one
flat one what about a Hollow Earth just
a planets Chell levitating around
absolutely nothing how would the laws of
physics work on that Hollow Earth would
we be able to dig a hole all the way to
its center and if we did what would
being in that centre feel like this is
what if and here's what would happen if
the earth was Hollow we've never made
the journey to the Earth's core but we
have been studying earthquakes in her
geomagnetic field long enough to know
what's inside our planet spoiler alert
it's dense and boiling hot but we didn't
always know that learning about how our
world works took a lot of time and
brought out some bizarre theories one
scientist even decided that the earth
was an inverted sphere with the entire
universe hidden inside Hollow Earth was
also in the list of possibilities but
how would a planet like that work the
quick answer is it wouldn't a hollow
earth would collapse inwards on itself
and become a smaller sphere why because
of gravity one of the four fundamental
forces in the universe gravity would
bring all parts of the crust toward one
another
making the Hollow Earth just impossible
but where's the fun in that
let's assume somehow the Earth's crust
could levitate without collapsing on
itself well that wouldn't be much fun
for us either most likely there would be
absolutely no life on the planet because
for starters there would be no
atmosphere the atmosphere of the earth
protects us from solar winds and space
radiation it needs a magnetic field and
the planets gravity to keep it in place
the magnetic field is generated in the
Earth's core which would be absent in a
hollow planet no core means no magnetic
field and no magnetic field means that
the earth would be pretty dead
a Hollow Earth would also lose a lot of
mass since most of it is accumulated in
the planets inner part the core and the
mantle and we're not just talking a few
kilos like what you put on during your
last visit to Grandma's but rather 5.9
sextillion tons a Hollow Earth would be
less than 0.4% of its current mass the
gravity on a Hollow Earth would be so
weak it wouldn't be enough for you to
stick to the planet you'd fly away into
space that's of course if you could make
it through all the solar radiation now
let's imagine that the Hollow Earth's
mass and gravity were no different from
real-life earth we'd still have no
atmosphere due to the lack of a
geomagnetic field but at least we'd
solve the gravity problem so that you
could stay on the planet the surface of
that Hollow Earth would be a very
hostile place but with no core of
boiling iron would you be able to move
under the planet's crust drilling
through the Earth's crust would be much
harder as it would have to be formed
from a very dense material to make up
such a mass when you finally managed to
dig through the 30 kilometer thick crust
and stepped into the interior of the
planet you'd experience zero gravity
since any gravity and a Hollow Earth
would have to be coming from the crust
gravity would just cancel itself out and
its influence on you would be zero
you'd be floating back and forth forever
lost inside an empty planet
don't forget your spacesuit you'll need
it to provide oxygen and pressure to
keep breathing until you run out of
oxygen
drifting inside the earth without a
spacesuit would be like stepping into
the vacuum of space trust me you don't
want to experience that and next time
you feel empty inside remember that the
earth you're sitting on isn't maybe in
the future we'll travel beyond Earth and
stumble across a planet that is Hollow
but that's a story for another what if
[Music]